welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
in this video we're going to be breaking
down 81 of our favorite details in
lovecraft country
now the season starts off by introducing
us to atticus
through his dreams in this we see as the
korean war vet has flashbacks to his
time in the war
which becomes a pivotal plot point in
episode 6.
take meets a version of gr which is
meant to resemble an alien
and when he wakes up we can see that
he's reading the jung carter novel a
princess of mars
which this scene is a reference to in
the background we can also see the
tripods from the hg world's war of the
worlds novel
as they torch the landscape during the
scene we come face to face with the
beast cthulhu
which is synonymous with lovecraft's
work the monster then gets split in half
by none other than jackie robinson
and robinson was the first african
american to play major league baseball
he's present in tick's dreams because
the character was brought up hearing
stories from his mother and father
about how they were saved by a man with
a baseball bat during the tulsa massacre
in episode 9 this is actually revealed
to be atticus
who time traveled to the event and it's
nice that we get a tease of its year
on the bus we see atticus and another
black passenger
forced to sit at the back and above them
hangs a sign which reads
this part of the bus for the coloured
race this is actually a reference to a
classic photograph
which depicted segregation on buses it
isn't the only riff on a historical
image either and when tick and co
are driving through the country they
pass an ice cream stand in which a black
family are forced to stand at the
coloured side
whilst they're ignored by the white
staff members this is actually a
reference to an image taken by gordon
parks
who documented segregation in the civil
rights era
another reference to parks appears not
long after when we see a mother and
daughter
standing below a sign that says coloured
entrance the image is almost
exactly how we see it in the show and
it's great that the creative team were
able to lace the series with such detail
on the road the group are harassed at a
gas station and when driving away
we see an advert for anjemima behind
them jemima
very much plays into the mummy
stereotype and this moment showcases how
black people were ostracized by white
people
whilst they were happy to use their
image to sell products and commodities
we actually see the duality between
advertisements for white men
and and jemima later in the season in
the episode's strange case
williams stands in front of an advert
for wrigley's which shows white men as
young
strong and strapping who don't know why
i said like that anyway jemima on the
other hand
is more of a maternal looking figure
showing that she and black
people in general were only deemed to be
good enough to look after white people
and provide them with food
recently uncle ben's removed their
mascot from their packaging
as they felt it gave off the wrong kind
of vibes and played on stereotypes which
i feel the show is hinting at
the show also has an advert for cream of
wheat in episode 8
and just recently he too was removed
from the packaging
as the company felt that it reinforced
certain stereotypes
in strange case ruby gets given an
outfit which is similar to jemima's
clothing
and when wearing this she has to perform
a job for christina
further hammering homeless aesthetic the
group stopped off at a restaurant
which we learn used to be a safe place
for black people
however we quickly discover that it's
now under white ownership
and that the original venue was burned
down by racists in the area
george tells tick of the time that
british soldiers burned down the white
house
and in order to cover up the burn marks
the walls were painted white
so from this we know that the black
owners were either killed
or forced out of it and then the white
vandals likely moved in
they literally painted the walls white
which symbolically showed they're taking
over of the property
and there's a lot going on in the
subtext here the episode also has
tick coming across his father's favorite
book which just so happens to be
the count of monte cristo this work
centers around a man that becomes
imprisoned
and after escaping captivity he sets out
on a quest
for revenge this pretty much sets up
montrose's arc
as after escaping his cell in episode 2
he helps bring an end to the bright
whites
who are responsible for his imprisonment
episode 6 also references this
and we see gr attempting to spoil the
ending for tick without even dropping a
spoiler alert
however she's only seen the movie and
the book ending is different
which could hand out how the media and
the history books in general
portray things differently to the way
they actually happened
when taking kogo looking for montrose in
episode 2
they find that he's managed to tunnel
his way out and this is actually a
reference to the shawshank redemption
with the tunnel reveal
being framed exactly the same as it is
in that movie
on top of this the second episode also
has references to other films
such as the wicker man we see children
dancing around a maypole in the village
of autumn
and the creative team said that this was
put here intentionally
to call back to the horror classic
there's also a mention of the
necronomicon
which you'll be very familiar with if
you're a fan of the evil dead franchise
the episode itself is titled whitey on
the moon and at one point we hear the
poem being read by gil scott herron
the poem discusses how the us government
put countless amounts of money into
putting a white man on the moon
whilst black people on earth still lived
in poverty this idea of white people
making advancements
at the suffering of black people is
central to this episode
as it revolves around samuel braithwight
attempting to gain
immortality through killing atticus we
learn that atticus descends directly
from a man known as titus braithwight
who william calls awfully kind awfully
kind is an oxymoron
as it's impossible to be awful and kind
we learn more about titus throughout the
season and though
he was known as a kind person in real
life he pillaged african villages
and was heavily involved in the slave
trade episode 2
also opens with another nod to the
themes in this entry as we hear this
song
moving on up in the beginning this was
used on the 70s tv show the jeffersons
which was about a black couple living in
white high society
which is also what we see the characters
doing at the beginning of the entry
jump to episode 3 and we watch as letty
buys the winthrop house
after a spell of protection is put on it
later in the episode she
turns it into a safe haven for black
people and this is actually a nod to
winthrop avenue in chicago
which was a safe place for black people
in the 50s 60s and 70s
ruby herself also discusses trumbull
park in chicago
which became a center for racial
violence after a black family moved in
there
they were attacked by racist white
people and police protection was later
put in place
we actually see that the police in this
area don't really care
and later learn that they are complicit
in allowing racial tension to thrive
later in the episode they completely
ignore a burning cross
which is placed on the lawn at lady's
house this
symbol first became popular in the 1915
film birth of a nation
and not long after it was used by the ku
klux klan to terrorize black people
and it's absolutely horrifying amitil
also makes an appearance in the episode
and references to him pop up at several
times throughout the season
when we first see him we discover he's
taking a trip
and in real life emmett went to chicago
and was kidnapped by two white men who
later tortured and killed him
in episode 7 when lee is playing games
with the kids
one of them says they miss bobo as he
actually knew how to play
and this was actually till's nickname at
the time
episode 8 starts with his funeral and
later in the entry christina pays two
men to enact what happened to till
so that she can get perspective on it
episode 10 has diana scribbling on a
newspaper
and this is a headline which refers to
how till's killers were found not guilty
due to them being tried by an all-white
jury they later admitted to carrying out
the crime
but were not charged due to double
jeopardy laws and still stands as a huge
injustice
episode 4 revolves around the group
journeying to titus braithwick's hidden
vault
and this is given some nice
foreshadowing when we catch a child in
the library reading journey to the
center of the earth
the library also has the notable figure
of w.e.b dubois
hanging up and he was a key person that
fought for equality during the civil
rights movement
the episode is also laced with several
nods to indiana jones
and we see that they discover the
entrance to the vault by using light
which is similar to the staff of raw
there's also a bridge across a cavern
that they have to cross
which i think is a nod to the last
crusade not long after this bridge scene
montrose brings up jesse owens who was a
black athlete that won four gold medals
at the 1936 olympics
showing hitler that he was wrong in his
beliefs on aryan supremacy
jump over to episode 5 and we watch as
ruby transforms into a white woman
and gets to see society from another
point of view
the episode is called strange case and
this is a reference to the book's
strange case of dr jekyll and mr hyde
which i'm sure you're well aware of has
several similarities to this entry
when ruby goes through her first
transformation we can also hear a news
report talking about locust
and their metamorphosis process the news
reader says that locusts go through five
multi-stages before they finally feast
on everything
and ruby herself goes through five
transformations
in the end she goes wild with a shoe and
yeah
sticks a heel where the sun don't shine
now this is actually the heel of a
stiletto
which in culture is used as a sign of
female domination
thus her using it as a weapon carries a
lot of weight with it
a stiletto is actually the name of an
italian knife
and again we have this continuation of
something symbolically transformed to
appear another way
this newscast is also a reference to the
book metamorphosis
by franz kafka which follows a man who's
been transformed into a cockroach
butterflies also appear throughout the
entry and one even lands on the
newspaper that ruby is reading
butterflies also go through
transformations too and it's nice that
this image is dotted throughout
ruby also gets some vanilla ice cream
and due to jim crow laws at the time
black people were not allowed to have it
during ruby's journey we hear the poem
for coloured girls who have considered
suicide
and this discusses how much inequality
black women have to deal with
which is juxtaposed by ruby enjoying the
finer things in life
now we just passed the halfway point of
the video and if you're enjoying it then
please subscribe to the channel
as we do big breakdowns like this every
week and you definitely don't want to
miss them
anyway getting back into the list as
mentioned earlier
ruby completes a job for christina that
involves placing a regeneration stone in
captain lancaster's office
she sees lancaster take his shirt off
and he has a black body underneath it
which foreshadows the character
kidnapping black people and using them
as transplants
this was actually set up in episode 3
when we learned that hyrum epstein had
been experimenting on black people
epstein is actually supposed to be a
reference to joseph mengele
who carried out several experiments on
humans during the second world war
in this episode we also learned that
christina and william are one in the
same
and this is hinted at when the latter
takes off his shirt to reveal the mark
of kane
hanging up alongside his shirt are also
dresses
which is a really subtle indicator of
exactly what's going on
up next is episode 6 which opens on gr
watching meet me in st louis the title
of this episode itself is actually meet
me and daegu
which is a little nod to the film we
learn that gr is a kumio
which in korean folklore is a
nine-tailed fox that feeds upon men
hakumeo can also transform into a
beautiful woman
and the episode wrestles back and forth
over whether gr
is still gr or not shia attends
something known as a meeting
which is a form of speed dating in korea
when discussing her date
a friend says to her that he's as dull
as ditch water
the phrase in the west is of course dull
as dishwater
so here's saying ditch water hints at
how poverty stricken the people
are episode 7 is packed with easter eggs
and the title itself i am is a reference
to the bible in which god named himself
i am that i am hippolyta goes out on a
road trip to discover what happened to
george
and along the way she rides past bessie
springfield who was the first black
woman to ride a motorbike across the u.s
hippolyta herself goes on several
journeys and she meets an alien called
beyonce
as in as in beyonce yeah yeah they can't
all be bangers
now she also comes face to face with
josephine baker
a civil rights activist who found
notoriety as a dancer in france
freda carla two appears in the episode
and the pair were rumored to have a
relationship at one point
hibalaya also becomes the leader of an
amazonian tribe
and hippolyta herself and pop culture is
actually the mother of wonder woman
who too is an amazonian during the
warrior fight scene
we can hear this song fire which is
actually sung by a band that have a
black female singer for their main
vocals
hippolyta ends up going on a journey
across the multiverse
and here she encounters aliens who would
later end up making an appearance in the
comic books that she gives to diana in
episode 10.
we also see that her ship looks like an
alternate version of woody
the car that she used to travel about
the episode in the entry ends with take
getting a lovecraft
country book and this fourth wall
breaking moment is meant to signify to
the audience
that the show is going off in its own
direction that's different from the
source material
as mentioned earlier episode 8 has
emmett till's funeral in it
and we see as people outside it vomit
and complain about the smell
this is because tyl's mother held an
open casket funeral
to show the world what had happened to
her son throughout the episode diana is
chased by demons known as topsy and
bopsy
which are plays on the pick in any
stereotype these were first popularized
in the book uncle tom's cabin
which we see feature in the entry
released in the 1800s
this was the second best-selling novel
of the century
next to the bible and it drove a lot of
the anti-slavery movement which
eventually led to the civil war
we are introduced to topsy and bopsy as
they appear behind diana eating ice
cream
and as mentioned earlier vanilla was not
served to black people
so this hints that something else is up
with them diana also wears a chicago
american giants cap
and these were actually a fully african
american team that were based in chicago
which is where this episode takes place
tick arrives home at one point to find
letty angelio's shoes
outside his house in korea one is
expected to remove their shoes upon
entering someone's home
and this is because koreans tend to eat
and sleep on the floor
and thus not removing one's shoes is
seen as very disrespectful
in the entry d loses her arm and we hear
that tick met a woman in the future with
a robotic one
so the seeds were the reveal in the
finale are sewn here
episode 9 involves jumping back in time
to the tulsa massacre
and there are several things that pop
here such as the dreamland theater
this was actually destroyed during the
tulsa riots and you may remember that it
too appeared in watchmen
when the sign fret became dr m during
the burning scene towards the end of the
entry
we hear the poem catch a fire by sonia
sanchez which is about black people
using their oppression
as a driving force in order to liberate
them as the city burns
montrose discusses several members of
the dead and it's a failing tribute to
the real-life people who actually lost
their lives during the atrocity
and finally is episode 10 which is
called full
circle circles are used at several
points in the entry
and the entire show comes well full
circle now initially a circle is drawn
in
salt to summon titus bright white later
there's a giant one drawn around the
lodge
and atticus is put on a circular
contraption atticus becomes somewhat of
a savior figure in this entry
and he's placed in a crucifixion pose
before sacrificing himself
he's also baptized and this is of course
bringing up a lot of christ's symbolism
finally the last one there's a big clue
that christina is ruby
which comes during the card journey ruby
happily sings along to the song shaboom
but earlier in the season when
discussing the tune she says it's
shaboring
thus we can take from this that it was
actually really christina
anyway that concludes our video and you
know what thank you so much everyone
who's watched through all of our
breakdowns
and added these easter eggs into the
comments and so on i've been writing
this video for a while
so i appreciate you sitting through it
and i hope you enjoyed watching it as
much as we did making it
don't forget we're also giving away
three copies of the marvel phase one box
set
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of october so make
sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early and please
consider clicking the join button below
you can always come chatters on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care
peace
you